l'innovation la qualité de vie le
développement durable et la protection
les priorités des candidats ensemble
pour les yvelines dans le cadre des
élections départementales un programme
pour les six prochaines années dans la
continuité des actions mises en oeuvre
lors du dernier mandat
on est partagé entre les missions
fondamentales qui sont les nôtres je
pense en particulier à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
notre mission aussi avec les communes
donc d'accompagner les communes je pense
aux bonus environnemental
et puis notre mission aussi de faire que
on vivre mieux sur ce territoire
c'est aussi construire quinze nouveaux
collèges en bois et en matériaux éco
responsable financées jusqu'à 100 euros
les activités culturelles et sportives
des jeunes de 11 à 18 ans ou encore
crédit villages d'enfants pour faciliter
l'intégration des enfants pris en charge
par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
les enfants qui sortent de l'aide
sociale enfants sont pas tous des moyens
de s'intégrer
heureusement dans la société il faut
donc que nous nous améliorons et pour
cela nous pensions que il faut sortir de
la logique de foyers pour rentrer dans
une logique de village qui soit dans une
dimension plus familial le plus petit
plus humaine sans doute l'équipe menée
par pierre bédier souhaite amplifier la
collaboration avec les hauts de seine
une volonté aussi de poursuivre les
investissements dans les infrastructures
une participation financière des deux
départements pourraient être engagées
pour la ligne 18
nous sommes tout à fait prêts à prendre
comme nous l'avons fait pour les hommes
avec nos voisins et amis du 92 à prendre
une partie du financement pour faire
versailles roissy au total ce sont 21
une action qui sont proposées aux
yvelinois dans le programme des
candidats ensemble pour les yvelines
pour rappel les élections
départementales se tiennent les
dimanches 20 et 27 juin